- It is a welcome and a joy
to say hi to Julianne Moore.
(audience clapping)
Hi, you are so beautiful.
You look so good.
Congratulations on your show.
I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you.
Spoken by the woman who
literally is my beauty style,
hair, eyes, skin, nose, face,
and decorative icon, by the way.
- Thank you.
- We'll get into that.
But your family, like your love story
with your husband is
such relationship goals.
And I know you just posted
something about your anniversary.
And I remember years ago,
hearing you two got together,
you had made this film,
and you fell in love.
And I just, your love story
is such relationship goals.
- Well, I will tell you,
you know what's really funny about it?
Is that you say years
ago, it was 24 years ago.
That's what's shocking to us.
We're like we met 24 years ago?
- Can I ask you a weird personal question?
Like you and your husband are so amazing,
Like, do you have any tips
for people on like an
awesome, like union marriage?
Like, do you have a secret?
Do you have something to turn to?
Like, I think a lot of us, you know,
would love to know if you
have any tips or insights.
- I think, I mean, the
only thing that I can say,
I think that you both have
to really want to be married.
I do, feel like I've seen situations
where things aren't
working out for people,
because one of the, one of the members
of the couple doesn't want to be there.
So, I think if you're both
invested in it working out,
and that, and that's important,
and then you really have
to have a good time.
My God you have to,
I think they really
have to make you laugh.
If they don't make you
laugh, it's just deadly.
And somebody asked me the other day
if it felt like a long time.
And I was like, oddly, no, it doesn't.
I mean, I think that's
what's been nice about it.
It doesn't feel like a long time.
And, but now, I mean, our kids
are, our kids are 18 and 22.
How old are your kids now?
- They're six, Frankie's
six, she'll be seven,
and Olive turns eight,
like any second, so.
- Oh my goodness.
- I know.
- Are they in school virtually?
They must be.
- No, they went back.
So, and I had such a struggle with it
because as a parent, I wasn't sure.
And for the show's sake, I was worried
about what they were
going to bring back in.
But then I thought, oh my God,
what a Hollywood stage
nightmare mother I would be,
like, you can't go to school
because mom can't get sick at her job.
(Julianne laughing) So
I was like, guess what?
We're just rolling the dice.
Because every time you try
to plan, it's so terrifying,
and everything keeps
having to pivot anyway.
So I feel like it's almost
rude to wrestle anymore,
and just succumb.
Well, you know, my daughter
was a camp counselor
at this little camp, you
know, that she went to
when she was a kid, she was
always a camp counselor there,
and she had three and four old girls,
and the counselors all wore masks,
but the kids didn't cause
they were too little,
and everybody was fine.
They were all okay.
And those little kids were
all over her, you know?
So, I do think with testing
and everything like that,
things can be done safely, but it's hard.
It's really hard.
- I know all of a sudden
the hug has so much
more than just a hug.
Like, will I get sick hugging you?
Will I make you sick?
This is a lot going into a quick hug.
Oh wait, is your daughter on Tik Tok?
- Yeah.
- Have you joined her for some Tik Tok?
- There might've been a
couple, but you know, nothing.
I don't, I'm, oh no.
Yeah, there might've been something.
I think there was one where
I was doing the dishes
and she went, it was some Tik Tok
where you supposed to like do something
with your mom or something.
Anyway, I participated in
that without my knowledge.
- I'm excited that we both
have a love of design.
- Yes, yes, absolutely.
It's my hobby.
It's my big hobby.
- Where did it all start for you?
The love of design.
- It was my mother, you know?
I mean, I don't think I realized
how much I was absorbing
from her, but she was the kind of person
who really cared how things looked.
And she, you know, my
parents were students
for a really long time, so
they never had any money.
So she would do things like
make her own slip covers,
just always sewing things, and
refinish furniture herself.
And she loved to tour
historical homes and stuff.
She would bring me along with her
and she would do things like
organize the silverware drawer
a certain way just
because it looked better.
And I realized that I just
sort of absorbed it all
and stuff that I care about now too.
But yes, all I want to do is
look at Architectural Digest.
That's my favorite thing.
- So your mom is like Martha
Stuart and Marie Kondo
before they existed?
- She kind of was, I mean, she was,
I think not at that same level, but yeah,
she definitely was
interested in that stuff,
and it just rubbed off.
- I think sometimes in the
world of design, you know,
things are expensive, or
they come from, you know,
another person's taste,
and so your mom was like,
how she made things.
That's like gifting in design,
like the best things are
stuff of what you bring
to the table, your craft,
your sense of style.
- Oh my gosh, yeah absolutely.
It's funny, when my kids were little
and they, but they would bring
home all of these things,
you know, they bring home so much artwork.
I wouldn't, I didn't
keep all of it, you know,
but I always found something
that I really loved
that they made, and I'd
frame it or keep it around,
and it's sort of indistinguishable
from the other things that I've collected
because I was even specific about that.
But it has to have some
kind of a meaning to you.
I mean, that's what
makes a home interesting.
And I think even in terms
of furniture designers,
I'm always interested
in seeing their hand,
you know, their craft.
That's what I love to live with.
It's a representation of
people and what they do.
(inspiring music)